haha the Joe Rogan experience did you
find any root vegetables or any wow
there's uh there's not a lot of that up
there there's lichen so I boiled the
reindeer lichen now that's taste like
real bland it's really kind of acidic
it's not great for eating but I would
mix it with my moose meat just to get
carbs like some herbs maybe that's where
all the caribou eat right yeah yeah
that's weird
a weird that's weird but you can turn
into an animal you know just take a pile
of it's weird stuff too right yeah so
that was you have no seasoning or
anything right right but man I gotta
tell you I didn't you you know you know
elk do but man I didn't miss it at all
it was so good from the first bite to
the last man hmm do you saw the extra
boost job yet a knife a Leatherman yeah
yeah oh just a leather the leather
mister you you butchered the moose with
a leather yeah yeah oh I think I've got
the moose finally at like noon and then
I think I was done cutting it up and
hauling it by like ten o'clock that
night and do you have a sharpening stone
or anything yeah it's a rock you know
it's just a regular fine laying around
you sure no it looks like it might work
well did it work yeah that's so crazy to
rely on a Leatherman that little tiny
out yeah well you got only so many items
no and I wanted the wire cutters I
wanted the little saw for crafting stuff
you know so I've figured if my worst
problem is that I have a small knife to
cut up a big game I'll be pretty happy
was there anything that you wished you
brought that you didn't yeah I would
have taken probably a gill net instead
of my saw I took a saw and I almost
never used it yeah yeah yeah you thought
you and user for trees or yeah I just
thought for project just be a calorie
saver rather than using your axe button
it was kind of a risk I took and it
ended up not being so that was really
wild that's pretty good though yeah yeah
yeah it was nice for building I built
like a 12-foot tall cache where I stored
all my moose meetings
nice for that so what other objects did
you bring you brought a tarp you brought
in line fishing line you guys a [ __ ]
James the best feral rod what is a Ferro
rod that's like that sparker you know
you scrape it and oh that's how you
started your fire yeah yeah mmm
fishing line and hooks all barb with how
many hooks a job 25 but yeah last ones a
bow and you're allowed nine arrows only
yeah did you think about constructing
arrows yeah I thought and I was thinking
uh by the time I got the moose you know
it was early enough that I didn't really
need to make arrows but I was thinking
if I want to shoot more at squirrels I
better make some arrows trapping wire
what is that that's just just thin gauge
wire like money gauge wire and would use
that for five hours snare and rabbits
hundreds of snares out and then I built
you know for building my fishing poles
mm-hmm and did that in a sleeping bag
yeah my bag brought up [ __ ] yeah
sleeping bag forty a nice point up rocks
throw it in there with okay yeah and
then a multi-tool crazy didn't bring a
knife just a multi-tool I guess that
makes sense though if I was looking at
that list like what would I take off for
a knife yeah it's gonna read that saw
would you take if you didn't have the
song I would have taken a gill net I
ended up making a gill net out of the
paracord but I think that would have
been useful wow it's crazy you only get
ten things
yeah puts the pressure on oh my goodness
it does so once you shot the Moose and
you you had all that meat and then what
did you do with your time after that I
kept busy I just always assumed somebody
else was gonna get something so I was
like you know I'd spent a lot of time of
right after getting the mousse like
preserving it smoking it trying to store
it where it would be safe because
everywhere you put it something's
getting it you hang it in trees and the
birds are pecking it you know you
everybody's going for it you have a tarp
that you could cover it with well I only
had the tarp for my shelter and I didn't
that would have been that I was an item
I also thought had I known I was gonna
get something big it would've been nice
to have a tarp but yeah
yeah it was a lot of work protecting my
meat but then also just continued
fishing continued you know all that kind
of stuff after you got the Wolverine out
of the picture was there any other I got
the Wolverine I was so happy I was like
yeah I just got to eat and live and then
like two days later I was sitting there
frying up some meat and and I've never
even been able find on the internet a
good Wolverine sound but another one
another one came and I just hear it out
in the woods Anika no it's like a witch
in the woods I was like I was like just
praying like I think I made that up
right yeah but sure enough II started
coming around but we were only we have
regulations right so you can't kill you
don't kill one Wolverines those oh yeah
then I was just on defense mode trying
to set up like I'd like set up all these
cans so that I'm gonna walk through with
you know did Clank and then I died wait
yeah I'd be like way
[Laughter]
[Applause]